yeah hello and welcome to this video
play I am Sherlock here so we probably
get a banker coins into air it's
amazingly popular already know yeah I
recently got into trouble here not be
five was played against me and yeah I
made a mistake there by capturing on b5
at the wrong moment so he just teaches
takes on okay should be okay for black
I'm material is equal and it's no
particular problem inside me just 97
okay let's get a night before in the mix
okay no reaction whatsoever okay so yeah
let's play night before I guess so is
there said check tech don't don't see
one I can take only five a couple of
times but it's not great
hmm that's not great
it's a little bit difficult here I
cannot really give him the deep on I'm
just taking on your 540 that a little
bit hmm Queen a 683 my night has no
squares see 493 would be cool but I
don't really get this get this working I
mean after taking on d6 it's also some
kind of fork weird don't know I don't
know something something went wrong if I
place you for here rookie 793 yea the
deep one is pretty quick but rook takes
be too is a threat so let's do this
rookie 793 could still be okay I mean
I'm not a porn down sometimes in the
bank oh you're so used to being a pawn
down that you sometimes I think okay I
need you need to find compensation for
the Parliament here I'm not a porn down
anyway so I can just play play normal
moves in a way so let's see here 93
looks like like a reasonable threat so
rookie 793 I don't know be twists is
under attack and not so easy for him
maybe you can take it 793 rookie 2 or
something it's a bit passive though it's
not a move you like to play but 93 is
coming here anyway yeah okay 93 what's
the point yeah I can take be to hear
right that that threatens all kinds of
stuff or even look checks b-2s is a move
that attacks f2 and the nine
I'm not sure I couldn't know I know I
couldn't have taken on f2 or the night
but it was close
yeah what's he doing now this one I can
take f to him he's got maybe he's got
some nighty for coming up no look
everyone maybe this book is not
protected yeah he's got to go from one
after the capture time morning isn't all
that clear
I can just go back then but it's not
really great not happy here with this
weird not happy maybe just cost 94 here
9006 something something went wrong I
don't know what maybe I should have
taken on b2 with the night instead of
the rook maybe yeah that deep one is a
bit dangerous
my sequin is also not that bad okay he's
playing on time now right wants to try
for the time check oh yeah whatever ads
of course just to draw but I have no
time black for Finn's on time yeah just
a bad game somehow hey I spent too much
time I don't know anup yet there's any I
have to play this at the end anyway yeah
and here of course I should just win
then I'd be two wins this is not just
taro I mean it's not that I saw the
movie yeah when I thought would be to is
also good but I didn't I just didn't see
that this is a good move it defends the
night and it gets this new idea into the
game not playing well today what kind of
the same just gifting points left and
right I mean of course you should never
lose anyway but by now the time was it
wasn't was a big problem yeah okay yeah
we have 13 seconds him now I took far
too long after you file this is this is
really the thing I didn't I like he I
didn't want to do this looks a bit yeah
I wanted to make something nice a work
but this is of course okay I mean as
mentioned black
not a porn down I can switch this on
anterior of course has to take it seven
this is just not good running into all
kinds of things ever met just an idiot
sometimes you just take it and what's
what's going on yet I'm attacking stuff
left and right justjust winds down this
is just just winning the game nothing
more nothing less pretty awful yeah I
just thought that rupee to is also good
somehow but I didn't see Queen deform
and yeah it's it's kind of ok for him I
will see to it stronger now it was
already it was already screwed up
screwed up here pretty clearly yeah
don't very nice at the moment I don't
know not a good touch for those for
those key moments ok thanks for watching